in some of the wealthiest corners of the
world the very rich are putting their
money towards building underground
bunkers to survive the apocalypse these
subterranean safe havens are designed to
withstand disasters like dirty bombs
pandemics and their aftermath but if
humanity crumbles on the surface could
you actually survive underground long
term how could you make sure you don't
run out of food where would you get your
power and should you invite your friends
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we were forced to live
underground first things first if we
want to survive in our new underground
homes it's going to take some serious
planning and supplies you'd probably
want a team with you to keep up with all
the work required to keep things going
but even if you had all that could your
mind handle all the psychological
dangers involved before we worry about
anything else the first thing we need to
figure out is how to power our bunker
well it's safe to assume that any
cataclysmic event would have wiped out
our power grid and any power workers are
probably dead or hiding in their own
bunkers so the obvious solution would be
just to plop a bunch of solar panels
down and then we'd be good right
not exactly depending on what the
conditions are like above the surface
solar panels may not even receive any
Sun and we probably couldn't venture out
to maintain them instead of looking up
we might be better off digging further
down to take energy from the earth
itself geothermal energy is the heat of
the earth extracted from hot water and
rock it it'd probably be our best bet
[Music]
once we got the lights on we'd need to
focus on access to fresh water again
seeing that it's probably too dangers to
leave the bunker it's going to be more
difficult than just setting something up
to collect rainwater so we'll dig some
more until we hit a source but we have
to be very careful for one thing all
this water would need to be purified
before drinking and we'd also have to
contain the source to avoid flooding
this is a bunker not an
Poole all this digging would make us
pretty hungry so we'd have to stock up
on lots of canned fruit before bunkering
down non-perishable meals would do
wonders but the supply would only last
so long if we wanted to outlast it we'd
have to set up some hydroponic gardens
to grow fruits and vegetables and we'd
be best to bring some farm animals with
us for food hey we never said this had
to be a small bunker one thing most
people don't think of in these highly
sophisticated survival plans is what we
would do with our poop if we just let
our bodily waste pile up somewhere we're
probably gonna get sick real quick so
why not put it to good use our waste
could be employed to fertilize the soil
weave our vegetables with we just need
to install some sort of ventilation even
if we could figure all this out there's
still one more thing we could fall
victim to our minds because we wouldn't
be receiving our daily dose of sunlight
we wouldn't get any vitamin D and that
would make us depressed and irritable
add to that the fact that we'll all be
cooped up in the same space and things
could get ugly pretty quickly so even
though surviving underground is
technically possible it would require
extensive resources and would probably
be pretty miserable but hey these are
billionaires trying to build bunkers
right now so maybe one of them will
figure out a way to safely replicate the
sun's rays but that's a topic for
another what-if
[Music]